three building blocks that most of these
Consulting interviews consist of the
first is the CV review part so in the
interview section where the interviewer
talks with you about your CV the second
is the experience interview where the
interviewer deep Dives with you into
specific situations specific experiences
that you had in the past and the third
is the case study interview this is the
section where the interviewer discusses
with you a real business problem and
wants to understand how you handle these
kinds of problems as a candidate because
of course this will be the task that you
are facing as a consultant